Claude maluré vous vouliez pas forcément
parler des insoumis mais puisque Tam me
demande de vous poser la question j'en
suis voilà j'y suis contraint mais voilà
on entend ces ces sénateurs notamment LR
qui demande de dissoudre la France
insoumise alors c'est certes très
difficile à faire et c'est même pas
faisable techniquement mais qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de ce de ce message
politique DLR je pense que c'est pas la
peine de dissoudre les insoumis ils sont
en train de se dissoudre tout seul
chaque chaque épisode politique depuis
plusieurs mois il ne cesse de tomber
plus bas cesse de s'éloigner de plus en
plus de ce que pense le peuple français
il se réclame du peuple français et ils
sont en décalage de plus en plus fort
avec avec ce peuple euh je crois qu'il y
a même pas de commentairirees à faire
ils sont en train de
s'autodissoudre